IT'S 5 O'CLOCK IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
JOE BIDEN FACING SCRUTINY FOR
ANOTHER BLUNDER ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
ACCUSED OF TELLING A FALSE WAR
STORY WHILE TRAVELING TO
AFGHANISTAN WHEN HE WAS
VICE-PRESIDENT.
BIDEN SAID HE WAS TRYING TO
HONOR A NAVY CAPTAIN WHO REFUSED
TO RECEIVE THE SILVER STAR FROM
HIM.
>> EVERYBODY GOT CONCERNED.
THE VICE-PRESIDENT GOING UP IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS.
WE CAN LOSE A VICE-PRESIDENT.
WE CAN'T LOSE MANY MORE OF THESE
KIDS.
IT'S NOT A JOKE.
THIS GUY CLIMBED DOWN A RAVINE
AND CARRIED THIS GUY UP ON HIS
BACK UNDER FIRE.
THE GENERAL WANTED ME TO PIN THE
SILVER STAR ON HIM.
I GOT UP THERE AND THIS IS GOD'S
TRUTH MY WORD AS A BIDEN.
HE STOOD AT ATTENTION.
HE SAID I DON'T WANT THE DAMN
THING.
DO NOT PIN IT ME, SIR!
HE DIED.
>> THE "WASHINGTON POST" CALLED
OUT JOE BIDEN SAYING HE MIXED UP
SEVERAL EVENTS FOR A FALSE
NARRATIVE.
BIDEN WONDERING WHAT THE BIG
DEAL WAS.
>> I WAS MAKING A POINT HOW
COURAGEOUS THESE PEOPLE ARE AND
HOW INCREDIBLE THEY ARE.
THESE FALLEN ANGELS WE LOST.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEM
IS.
WHAT IS IT THAT I SAID WRONG?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S A LIE.
MOST PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT
POLITICIANS LIE.
I DO THINK THERE IS SOMETHING
GOING ON WITH BIDEN.
HE LOST A STEP.
IT'S ONE THING TO GAFFE.
HE COULD NOT REMEMBER PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S NAME THE OTHER DAY.
JUST CALLED HIM HIS BOSS.
WHAT MAKES THIS SUCH A BIG THING
GOING INTO THE NEXT DEBATE IS
THAT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO START TO FRAME IT -- IF
THEY TAKE OFF THE GLOVES -- THEY
CAN MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT BIDEN
IS TOO OLD AND YOU SEE HE IS TOO
OLD.
IT'S NOT ABOUT NEW IDEAS.
CAN THE PRESIDENT REMEMBER
INTELLIGENCE WHEN HE HAS TO MAKE
A DECISION IF HE GOES TO THE
OVAL OFFICE?
I THINK DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
ELECTABILITY THING.
IF YOU CANDIDATE CAN'T REMEMBER
THINGS, I DON'T THINK HE CAN GO
ON DEBATE STAGE AND DEFEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
>> LET'S NOT ATTRIBUTE THIS
GAFFE TO AGE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE OLDER THAN JOE BIDEN WHO
STILL GOT IT GOING ON.
GREG AND I, WE ARE SEASONED.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT.
YOU THINK IT WAS A HEAD INJURY?
>> NO, I AM SAYING THAT
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION IN YOUR BRAIN AND
YOU TRY TO PUT IT OUT YOUR
MOUTH, IT COMES ACROSS LIKE, YOU
ARE JUGGLING THE STORY.
>> BUT HE DID JUMBLE IT.
>> HE JUMBLED IT.
THE FACTS ARE THERE.
MOST PEOPLE KNOW JOE BIDEN'S
CHARACTER AND HIS VALUE SYSTEM
AND THAT HE VISITED IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN OVER 21 TIMES AS A
UNITED STATES SENATOR AND
VICE-PRESIDENT.
BUT THIS STORY THE WAY IT CAME
ACROSS, PEOPLE KNOW JOE BIDEN IS
HEARTFELT.
I CONTINUE TO TOUCH HIM AND
TOUCH YOU.
>> HE TOUCHES A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> HE TOUCHES WITH HIS HEART.
>> AND HIS HANDS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THE "WASHINGTON POST" WILL
TRY TO MAKE A BIG DEAL OUT OF
THIS.
>> HE TELLS A GOOD STORY.
HE IS LIKE A CHILD.
I WAS PRESIDENT OF MARS!
WE BUILT A BALLOON RAFT AND WENT
TO AUSTRALIA AND I MET LIONS AND
TIGERS AND GIRAFFES AND HAD THE
BEST PIE I EVER HAD.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM:
IT MAY NOT BE THAT FUNNY.
YOU CAN END A PRESIDENCY LIKE
THAT.
I AM NOT SURE YOU CAN START ONE.
YOU CAN'T START A PRESIDENCY
ALREADY SLOW.
I LIKE JOE BIDEN A LOT.
IF HE LEAD THIS IS RACE AND I
THINK HE WILL --
>> OH, WOW.
>> THAT'S FANTASY ISLAND WITHOUT
TATTOO.
IT'S ALL SUPPORTING CAST.
IF HE LEADS I DON'T KNOW WHO
ELSE IS THERE.
THERE IS SOMETHING ELSE THERE
THAT MAKES IT SO THE JOKE IS NOT
THAT FUNEY.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE HE DRIVING NEWS
STORIES ON HIS OWN.
THE STORIES ARE DRIVING HIM.
>> HIS DEFENDERS, THERE IS A
SPECTRUM.
IT'S NOT AS BAD AS THIS, SO IT'S
OKAY.
HIS MISSED STATEMENTS AND
MISSPEAKS AND GAFFS ARE NOT THE
SAME AS TRUMP'S DAILY ASSAULTS
ON THE TRUTH.
TRUMP BENDS THE TRUTH AND AN
INSULT.
ALL OF THESE THINGS AS A VOTER I
DESERVE THE TRUTH ALL THE TIME,
END OF STORY, PERIOD.
I DON'T WANT MY
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF REPRESENTING
ME IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH SOMEONE
WHO IS GOING TO SAY THE WRONG
STORY AND BE CALLED OUT AND BE
HUMILIATED?
>> TO LAWRENCE'S POINT.
WE HAVE THE UPCOMING DEBATE.
ONLY TEN ON STAGE.
I HAVE A THEORY THAT ELIZABETH
WARREN OR BERNIE SANDERS WON'T
GO AFTER JOE BIDEN FOR THINGS
LIKE THIS.
I THINK THEY WILL GO AFTER HIM
FOR HIS RECORD LIKE KAMALA
HARRIS DID THE FIRST TIME AND
WARREN MAYBE HIS COZY
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CREDIT
CARD COMPANIES.
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE READY TO
TAKE THE GLOVES OFF AGAINST THE
FRONT RUNNER?
>> WHEN YOU GO AFTER JOE BIDEN
YOU ARE ALWAYS GOING AFTER
BARACK OBAMA.
YOU ARE ATTACKING SOME OF THE
POLICIES AND INITIATIVES OF THAT
ADMINISTRATION.
>> THEY WILL GO BACK TO THE
'90s?
>> PERHAPS THEY WILL.
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS THE NEXT DEBATE.
SOME OF THE CANDIDATES ARE STILL
STUCK IN SINGLE DIGITS.
THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET BACK ON THE NEXT STAGE AND
TO USE PERFORMANCE TO REALLY
HIGHLIGHT WHY THEY ARE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
>> JOE BIDEN CAN'T CONTINUE TO
USE PRESIDENT OBAMA AS A SHIELD.
THE REPORTS SAY THAT PRESIDENT
OBAMA SAID JOE, YOU DON'T HAVE
TO DO THIS AND EVEN PRESIDENT
OBAMA WAS CONCERNED ABOUT JOE
BIDEN DESTROYING THE LEGACY.
ALTHOUGH PRESIDENT OBAMA MAY NOT
GO ON THE ATTACK, THERE ARE
PLENTY OF ADVISORS OUT THERE
THAT DON'T MIND ATTACKING.
>> JOE BIDEN WOULD BE THE ONLY
ONE ON THE STAGE DEFENDING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
EVERYBODY ELSE SAYS IT DIDN'T GO
FAR ENOUGH LEFT.
>> YOU HAVE TO GO TOUGH ON JOE
BECAUSE TRUMP WILL SHOW HIM NO
MERCY.
IF YOU HAVE A FIGHTER YOU DON'T
TELL HIM TO RELAX ON THE BEACH
WHEN YOU ARE FACING A STEAM
ROLLER.
>> MOST AMERICANS KNOW JOE
BIDEN.
>> IF THEY SEE WEAKNESS?
>> THEY WILL TRY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT, BUT PEOPLE LIKE
HIM.
THAT'S WHY THEY DON'T WANT TO
TAKE HIM DOWN.
>> TRUMP, WHEN HE FACES BIDEN,
IF BIDEN IS CRUSHED, NO MATTER
HOW MUCH YOU LIKE HIM, IT WILL
BE OVER.
>> AND TO YOUR POINT, THEY KNOW
HIM, BUT THEY ARE NOT INSPIRED
BY HIM.
MAYBE THEY LIKE HIM BUT NO ONE
IS EXCITED ABOUT HIM.
ON THAT STAGE EVERYONE WILL
ATTACK NOT ONLY HIS POLICY BUT
PUT THEMSELVES ON THE OFFENSE
AND LOOK AT HOW INSPIRING I AM.
THAT WILL BE MAGNETIC.
>> WHAT IF HE GOES ON THE
OFFENSE?
>> THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
>> SAY WHAT HAVE YOU DONE
LATELY?
>> I WAS ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
IN IOWA WITH HIM.
HIS CAMPAIGN IS TRYING TO KEEP
HIM AWAY FROM THE PUBLIC.
HE HAS A TELEPROMPTER IN FRONT
OF HIM.
OTHER CANDIDATES WERE IN THE LOB
TOE GREET PEOPLE.
JOE WENT THROUGH THE BACK
DOOR -- THE CAMPAIGN REALIZES
THERE IS A PROBLEM GOING ON.
WHETHER IT'S MEMORY OR HE IS
JUST LYING.
THEY DON'T WANT HIM OUT THERE.
HE IS GETTING A LOT OF THINGS
WRONG.
>> THE KING OF LIES IS THE
PERSON WHO IS CURRENTLY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ACCORDING TO THE
"WASHINGTON POST."
I THINK THE VICE-PRESIDENT
MISSPOKE AND GOT HIS FACTS AND
STORY WRONG.
>> LAST WORD FROM YOU?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT TRUMP'S LIES
ARE NOT BASED ON A MENTAL
DEFICIENCY.
HE IS LYING FOR US.
HE THINKS THIS LIE WILL HELP US.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE HE IS LOSING